>> Tucker: I LIVE HERE AND SO DO
MY KIDS.
WE CAN AGREE ON THAT.
>> Tucker: LAST WEEK WE WELCOMED
A GUEST TO DISCUSS WHETHER
CHICAGO SHOULD BE A SANCTUARY
CITY AND WE HAD A SPIRITED
OBLIGATION TO REPRESENT AMERICAN
CITIZENS FIRST ABOVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE HERE ILLEGALLY?
>> I REPRESENT MY CITIZENS VERY
WELL, THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: OKAY -- YOU AREN'T
GOING TO SAY.
BLUE-EYED AND BLOND FOR YOUR
AMERICA.
>> Tucker: WHAT A LOATHSOME
LITTLE DEMAGOGUE YOU ARE TO SAY
THAT.
WE HAVE ANOTHER GUEST NOT IN THE
CITY'S EFFORTS TO PROTECT
CITIZENS FROM AMERICAN LAW.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON TONIGHT.
SO I DIDN'T MEAN TO GET INTO
SUCH A BITTER DEBATE WITH YOUR
COLLEAGUE BUT I WAS ASKING HOW
IT HELPS THE AMERICAN CITIZENS
IN CHICAGO TO DO THIS AND HE
CALLED ME A BIGOT IN RESPONSE.
LET ME ASK YOU THE SAME
QUESTION, DOES IT HELP PEOPLE
FROM CHICAGO ON THE IMMIGRATION
POLICIES.
>> OF COURSE NOT, IT DOESN'T
HELP ONE BIT.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT'S THE POINT
OF IT?
I THOUGHT THE POINT OF
REPRESENTING A CONSTITUENCY WAS
TO LOOK OUT FOR THE VOTERS.
>> THAT'S HOW I FEEL.
WE REPRESENT THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND CITY AND
PEOPLE HERE, I BELIEVE, YOU HAVE
TO BE HERE LEGALLY.
WHO VISITS IT.
THERE'S GREAT PEOPLE, GREAT
FOOD, BEAUTIFUL CITY BUT LIKE
ALL CITIES IT HAS ACTUAL
PROBLEMS, FINANCIAL PROBLEMS,
CRIME PROBLEMS.
YOU CAN'T CONVINCE ME ALL THE
POLITICAL ENERGY SPENT ON
CATERING TO PEOPLE WHO SHOULDN'T
BE HERE, THAT'S GOT TO DETRACT
FROM MAKING THE CITY BETTER FOR
EVERYONE ELSE.
>> WE HAVE A SERIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE IN THE CITY AND
CRIME PROBLEM AND WISH WE'D
CONCENTRATE ON THOSE THINGS
OPPOSED TO ILLEGALS IN OUR CITY.
>> Tucker: SO YOUR MAYOR'S ALL
IN AND ALDERMAN ARE ALL IN.
WHAT'S THE MOTIVE?
IT'S THE MAYOR AND ALDERMAN
SUPPORTING THE SANCTUARY.
THERE'S TWO OF US THAT DON'T
SUPPORT THE SANCTUARY CITY.
>> Tucker: BUT THEY'VE LEFT OF
THE SOUTH SIDE OF YOUR CITY
VIOLENCE DON'T LIKE IT?
>> YOU'LL HAVE TO GET ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE SOUTH SIDE,
TUCKER.
I KNOW IT BOTHERS ME.
I THINK THE MONEY COULD BE
BETTER SPENT.
IF WE STICK WITH OUR SANCTUARY
CITY POLICIES WE COULD LOSE $1
MILLION OF FEDERAL FUNDS.
I'M CONCERN ABOUT THAT.